yeah hello welcome to this new video was
on final let's see what I can do about
to start one hour of two minute games
and here we go first game and it's not
starting ok it is starting ok
yeah touch defense trying to play 44
here yep let's take and play you form
the some kind of setup I like oops what
what did i do them plate why 194 I
confused museum alright so let's use
this he's somewhere recaptured with the
porn quite a weird start here but now he
cannot defend age five okay let's play
this open up the position more grab this
pawn and now Bishop takes h5 would be
nice young getting the Bishop to g4
maybe yeah very nicely positioned pieces
yeah before make subs make this night
look a bit silly on a six I'm just
covering here so that he doesn't have
anything on these pieces saw a five I
don't need to castle at the moment still
have other useful moves right I thought
this wouldn't be possible because of the
g6 porn okay so now let's play rook t1 I
could have taken on b5 mm-hmm still a
bit rusty here it seems ok some more
pressure on d6 and ce4 would be a nice
smooth okay first let me distract his
piece them and now cover g2 only thing I
need to be aware of this of course some
rook takes 2-3 move like this okay now I
grab this one rugby 6890 saying okay I
can take him
Luke g3 I can just play king of one I
think he's just has a check all right so
grab here
let's just grab all the pieces here okay
yeah quite a shaky start took some time
and some weird stuff happening 94 in the
opening was pretty cool I want to play
e4 pawn to e4 summer I'd ended up being
94 okay so let's see okay the Schliemann
one of my blitz weapons to get active
play quickly my people don't seem to
know it so well also
yeah black it's got a nice center but I
need to be cautious it can be yeah stuff
like this but it's some quite quite a
lot of material here question is what
about 27 as the surpluses of play will
move Knight anywhere I place is six
maybe but this is not not bad at all
having two pieces for for look and quite
some activity yeah I think I can take
the Queen a8 covering the the night so
what now let's let's put the bishop here
using the the long diagonal so i can
just retreat him and then try to get
something going on now on f3 ok so maybe
here just trying to set up a discovery
okay you're threatening c5 maybe not a
real threat but close to close to being
annoying okay this route d8 didn't
really paid much dividends yeah it looks
nice somehow but some of my pieces are
not working so well I can just take this
heaven very bad
yeah so now I'm just two pawns down very
bad game
now maybe I shouldn't have to change
Queens to get some some kind of
swindling chances but what's hard not to
exchange yeah just material down and you
could just take it here okay so a for
maybe maybe I can somehow get to the a3
porn it's about the only idea that I'm
having at the moment Oh II actually
allows me to enter you can go but should
be five but at least I've got an a porn
don't mind so much to lose more material
so at least I've got something that I
can can play on
look T to rugby too I am if he takes it
doesn't really help okay I need to maybe
get the pawn to a to this would be nice
upon a2 yeah he's some got this this
poem
it's made right wow what a start so I
lost about nine minutes and lost another
10 points great okay only chance is
really super quick play and trying to
catch up quickly okay a Sicilian night
off somewhat somewhat rare line at least
how I played it but I'm trying to play
on the d5 square 94 I could have played
an IG form with the huge advantage
didn't do it so now no I'm good again
bg5 coming up g5 and 95 if you yeah with
your retreats okay maybe this first and
then 95 no why should have pretty big
but big advantage okay no I would like
to trap the Queen the queen of course
hmm
don't see how at the moment
yeah this Queen doesn't have any moves
okay I grabbed the material here this
precarious situation of his queen still
still persists could play 95 actually 95
takes rook age 3 wood would win the
Queen but he has got 97 now it's very
annoying
okay let's get out of shot of this it's
got 96 down unbelievable that black
still has a position after all this
terrible moves
my default
you can check here now okay but that's
it right no more miracle defense now
yeah the sugar should really be winning
now Brooke age three
okay we're at least
only wins help quick once
okay some sort of Kings Indian set up
the exchanged only five
yeah this is not too threatening for
black but don't have anything great all
right so maybe I can do something on the
default square white as we can turn to
form
yeah before I've not a phone
so this is not not a problem can I take
you for let's grab it
yeah i'm just a pawn up here juicy
central pawn up yeah white can still
fight but membership see form but I can
also grab this him it doesn't really
have anything for those two points
interesting going into a completely lost
end game it's not even possible to to
fight or something just completely lost
yeah i'll have to two passports this is
just too much
yeah everything wins
homes about five maybe I could have
played Bishop f5 yeah now we need to
allow me to enter and shift xp3 yam on
this one okay so I'm catching up a bit
here yeah kingscrusher in the lead was
six out of six cm and I'm not lucky with
my draw and so I am Suzanne
international master from India pretty
good opposition he's buy rating I guess
um together with myself the best play
and the tournament no I'm summer
butchered the move order here it's not
what I wanted somewhat worse position
but it's um it's so still okay it's
nothing terrible yet happening
yeah this f3 mover sir it's not very
beautiful in this position
want to go Bishop b3
night c4b should be three okay
yeah he allowed me to plead the fif
surprisingly not sure that this was good
just taking now threatening you take c6
and this just activates my pieces even
more
hmm this looks but shaky the smooth
maybe I can go nitey form this would
help
ok
kicking takes 90 for the Spurs good this
was nice ok
okay this looks quite comfortable for
black he hasn't played before though
yeah this looks very crude and MIDI
screwed where did some bits bit annoying
for white this pressure on f2 maybe you
can play Knights yeah stuff like this 94
this is all a bit risky what I'm doing
here I hope it's working out so no tech
here threatening shop at five now ship
f5 symbols i can take with the Queen
okay so I need to retreat
and maybe I should have kept this this t
seven square for the Queen this looks
quite few okay I don't lose the Queen I
hope so at least yeah um what what is
all this I'm I'm a porn up young okay on
the positive side I'm porn up but it's a
somewhat weird looking position okay
let's get out of here now I have a
pretty good Queen only five if you
cannot take here because of the hanging
night I wants to exchange Queens
hmm
yeah that's a good move probably no
don't want to draw but maybe I should
hear the position is really just worse
for me yeah bit idiotic to decline a
draw to be honest I'm just completely
lost here completely lost position oh my
god it's not even very difficult
I'm not blending rook for what
tournament playing like the absolutely
like absolutely complete [ __ ] here oh
my
okay an old Indian and we should play
form
I mean I'm playing so bad it's it was it
doesn't matter what I do be 44 whatever
okay I'm just okay I expected to Queen
takes of course
it's not done a big difference d success
the idea of course it's working with a
record so Bishop takes 95 and white wins
I'm just winning the bishop and the
whole Queen side
you
gaap order to catch up you would really
need to resign but of course it doesn't
okay the way I'm playing it's may be
completely justified but now you really
should should give up blundering another
piece
ok
I'm a rock and a piece up now
yeah but this is checkmate okay so hmm
yeah yeah mumbling on here super far
behind and now I've got scollard mate
coming up
didn't really try to refute this okay
come on let's play some some active
musea can stand this here want to open
up the position
alright so come on I don't mind this is
completely incorrect but I need to I
need to win quickly here
why did I sacrifice this piece again
okay this helped
terrible I really is trying to play my
normal stuff I'm just bad at those kind
of kind of sacrifices that are not
working but maybe mono just play normal
chest is better oops ah okay so maybe I
can do something with 95
i hopes yeah i can do something does
this helped it wasn't a bad move anyway
Queen h5 we can sir flex pawn structure
usually k a fringed ones
the ice playing very quickly
and I hope that this is this is ok for
me
a king position looks a bit precarious
but it's not clear at all what white
should do about it a threatening Bishop
f4 now winning the Queen maybe he
doesn't see it he does
okay let's exchange this bishop
yeah what is somewhat better here but
not not sure how much really okay he
blundered an exchange this rook doesn't
have anywhere to go oops that's
surprising okay I'm very helpful some
third place you are whatever i played
this guy very often okay we transpose
down into a normal kind of scandinavian
if I for so hard to believe
what
really rookie idea this is just supposed
to be working got to be kidding me
Bishop takes f7 also okay let's let's do
this now all right 10 points 10 points
behind kingscrusher so I somehow out of
nothing I made a big run here
yeah I actually hope that she takes on
f6 sound so that maybe I can okay could
have used the default but this isn't bad
either just going for this minority
attack on the queenside to some some
strengthening move cm
before now let's open it
so now i have d5 nice square on d5 oops
what I just I just didn't see see a
tangy unbelievable and why doesn't he
take now this rook is just saying for
nothing yeah I know I should resign but
um yeah unbelievable no
yeah okay oh well I know I shouldn't
should resign really but let's let's
play a couple of more moves really great
really great in this rook was just
hanging come on this must be one of the
worst tournaments for a while well
usually one of my better points and in
those blitzie when's is that i rarely
blend the material they really need to
make me or something get something
really going but I just blunt the pieces
here and this is checkmate okay I'm
still in the hunt here unbelievable
shouldn't really think too much about
what what would be if I were playing a
on normal strength then it was possibly
at this tournament already would have
been over okay so I'm pretty nice
position here still I can can blunder
rookie I'm really great to just took c8
now not exchange Queens so early so now
I'm threatening F form okay now I've
form winning a piece
yeah his King is also a problem to say
the least
yeah let's grab the Queen
nopes continues
okay yeah I'm in the lead yeah the other
guys seem to have their their problems
as well get some Rihanna game here
hoping for something quick oops yeah can
win some time here on those nights and
maybe it takes with the bishop i can
play 85 otherwise its ambit weakened
here of course not i would like we'd see
two okay so then do it with the lost
tempo here okay allows me to take
huh
yeah of course I want hmm
could take care
this is all very weird
all kinds of pieces hanging in the
middle here okay although you lose
I want to get rid of this Bishop
boundary for and Queen to h5 this is
what I want ok let's let's play it
simple ok it's it's rough game it's
working made in three
right
still in the lead
hmm he didn't really try to refute my
opening but it's not to grade so I mean
what I played this over the f5 was just
just not very good okay it's um just you
just an equal position here I've got an
extra Center porn which is which is nice
but doesn't help so much at the moment
okay it's weakening the Kings side maybe
I can get a bishop to our form okay so
now that so that's a weak porn and he's
got his hmm yeah but its opinion he
cannot take on d5 know it take
he's got his pants on on white squares
this is some and middle lane not much
but you can try I'll put everything on
dark squares now and let's try to get to
to the h three Pawn may be using zoosk
monks okay now he's got another porn on
a white square and what now what now
feel if he needs to move the king I can
I can enter here ok so I'm winning now
so this simple play really paid off
don't want him to enter only form not
necessary
of course he continues people simply
don't understand the concept of these
tournaments but ok I played on with a
Nix check with the crook down not so I
know it's odd you simply don't want to
resign but if he lets the clock run down
now then it's just a one okay so I'm
still in the lead battling it out with
kingscrusher
so another open Cillian
okay allowed me to play a five uh-huh
what is going on here
you played all this very quickly amazing
95 want i want to use a special p6
resource
yeah and i would like to exchange Queens
okay some ie5 me5 might be an idea
okay something entirely different be
sure before I don't get it all
rookie to
okay to quite annoying
I want to really want to get rid of the
Queen here he can play rook e8 maybe
I don't get it I can just take the
bishop now I am I blundering something
I don't see I don't see a threat here
I'll frag of ok I can just go to h3
right
hi the time I can just take this
forehead and sake
Wow whoo I didn't understand anything in
this game as it completely weird I'm 85
expecting the usual 1e form now I've got
the bloody England gambit which is
entirely incorrect but maybe I can get
something going anyway but I'm not good
at this those are incorrect gambit stuff
okay I can just take the Queen this
confuse beam ok so still still in the
lead despite playing really really
really weird chess ok let's try the
Evans gambit
wow this is flavor amazing I mean this
is a normal kind of motif but never see
it happen in the Evans okay here he
could have taken the bishop somehow he
didn't I don't know why so Bishop b5
whom I guess okay let's get get rid of
those pieces here maybe I can get some
summer tech going we should the f6 would
be very nice now how does he prevent it
actually this way okay maybe I can still
use this idea king queen f6b should be
five there will be five f6 maybe rookie
seven maybe rookie seven threatening
should be five queen bee to I can play
yeah I can play this now right yep very
nice okay about 20 points ahead of Casey
here so just one game nothing meaningful
okay so
this is some super crazy looking line
okay but don't worry so much about about
material anymore I play so strange today
so might as well second porn or more
okay so he returns the exchange
so now nature needs to take with the
pawn
okay maybe this I could take I can take
be to right now let's grab you to rupee
one I have oops is giving up the
exchange and this should lead to some
exchanges no deform
yeah the sea porn cause for concern of
course okay but I have rugae for coming
this helps a lot so now i can i can get
go to c6 with the king and then it's
pretty easy whoo French
our thoughts shouldn't be shouldn't be
playable for black but he tries to play
it anyway this c5 someone upon here
okay threatening 97 so he needs to play
some move that he doesn't want to play
well slightly okay may bring the bishop
to be three mmm Queen g6 go in g six or
this one
I try to exchange Queens Queen d2 we
would have had fish of h2 Queen g5 maybe
Quincy five you can take edge too but it
shouldn't be too bad for me five I will
get some pretty active pieces okay
doesn't doesn't see it even okay so I'm
still up on up but it's not great the
opposite colored bishops and my we can
pawn structure so quite a problem okay
but I can I can protect their for with
the King now and have a pretty good
knight on d5 so okay so let's play
before and c5 getting a passed pawn here
b5 also hanging a sixer play for North
such this is nice again okay if you
insist I take it
yeah this those pawns really should
should decide
none that is very passive cannot do much
yeah just a check
come on resign please I let the clock
run down okay so 30 points ahead of kc r
this guy again I plane so often and no
draw for heaven's sake
okay some crazy gambit line don't like
it to be honest shouldn't should have
played something else it's not
particularly good but always tricky
tricky to play in this bullet kind of
time controls okay let's grab this all
right so he wants to go 95 maybe here
where we can they can still play it
terrible
I don't see a moose
don't see a move roop take see fire rook
takes f6 this sort of idiotic attack
just going through a cracker why did
that tip took this bloody palm I just
just just not so easy to defend against
this stuff with with one and a half
minute on the clock usually I just play
a French and win because he has no idea
how to play those closed positions
alright so Queens gambit here I hope so
i can take the rook now okay in this
quick win sort of compensated for the
silly loss before at least and this
point was still hate to lose against
such an attack but yeah it's very crude
but with this time it's a it's dangerous
oh ok thanks close to fifty points now
ahead
okay i want to have a single okay i
wanted to play the exchange here have a
simple kind of position ok let's let's
do this don't want a complicated
position again we're blunder look or
something
gasps why do I play but should be too so
that this sudden night h5 even has night
h5 was just just nothing nothing moving
Bishop e2 and makes it truly am have
some sense okay nothing terrible
happened but just just awful play by me
ok so this piece needs to return wanted
to play Bishop h3 now but this is
actually hanging ok yeah just very
stupid play with me
I can actually take on h5 is this an
idea okay let's play this first this
shouldn't be too bad playing on the a
file all right so let's set this here
I've got two passes and he's got the
silly night on age five okay let's go
here
alright so how to advance the spawns I
could even take him maybe better and
then advance with the king came to see
for you okay and then I grab this I
don't mind so now I've got four points
or somewhat for palsy so let's push the
points now
you
okay I so what's have an H poem
right okay 50 points with three minutes
something to go this should be enough
really unless there's some why do I play
this crap really getting myself into
trouble with such a comfortable lead 25
okay so I'm actually able to castle at
some point the are come on sexy
exchanged looks very nice here night and
rook attacking also check coming
goodnight f4
the Andrew graph to cannot prevent rook
f2
isn't there made some we're adults you
made our queen f2 Queen f.2d to deform
that's the way to go
okay 50 points still 50 points ahead one
minute to go if this fails i'll eat my
head this bloody England gambit I really
sometimes have my problems with those
crappy gambits
don't want to cancel short here
maybe I can get a night to be five
attack attacking a bit of myself okay
let's get rid of the night first I mean
okay most likely this game won't be
finished anyway but due to the time just
40 seconds left
oops
mmm
yeah well okay the game won't be
finished just eight seconds left so it
doesn't really matter what's what's
happening here all right finished first
place I did it after some will create
the games rook blunders and whatnot I
actually want the thing yeah yeah Casey
getting second place 30 points behind me
yeah what can I say a pretty weird
tournament I played some some incredibly
stupid stuff but I had lots of quick
winter in the meantime so yeah well
thanks for watching I hope you enjoyed
it was a quite fun to watch out and talk
to you soon with the new video